WASHINGTON.
I'M SHANNON BREAM IN FOR BRET
BAIER.
BREAKING TONIGHT, AMERICANS
TRYING TO LEAVE AFGHANISTAN ARE
PLEADING WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FOR HELP.
A NUMBER OF THEM ARE ON CHARTER
PLANES, STILL BEING BLOCKED FROM
LEAVING.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS BLAMING
THE TALIBAN BUT NOT EVERYONE IS
BUYING THAT.
CORRESPONDENT TREY YINGST STARTS
US OFF TONIGHT FROM DOHA, QATAR.
HELLO, TREY.
>> SHANNON, GOOD EVENING.
THERE IS TENSION ON THE GROUND
IN AFGHANISTAN AS THE TALIBAN
CRACKS DOWN ON PROTESTS AND
CIVILIANS TRY TO FLEE.
>> CHARTER FLIGHTS FROM
AFGHANISTAN REOF MAIN GROUNDED
AN ESTIMATED 100 AMERICANS ARE
STILL STUCK IN THE COUNTRY.
A HANDFUL OF THEM IN THE
NORTHERN CITY OF MASRI SHAREEF.
THEY HAVE PLANES BUT AREN'T
PERMITTED TO TAKE OFF.
>> AS OF NOW, THE TALIBAN ARE
NOT PERMITTING THE CHARTER
FLIGHTS TO DEPART.
THEY CLAIM THAT SOME OF THE
PASSENGERS DO NOT HAVE THE
REQUIRED DOCUMENTATION.
>> WHILE SECRETARY OF STATE
ANTONY BLINKEN BLAMED THE
TALIBAN FOR HALTED EVACUATION
FLIGHTS A LEAKED EMAIL SHOWS
SOME AIRCRAFT ARE BEING DENIED
TAKEOFF BY THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
A SENIOR U.S. OFFICIAL SAYS
THERE IS NO WAY TO VET WHO IS
BOARDING THE PLANE, MAKING THE
RESCUE MISSIONS SUSCEPTIBLE TO
TERRORISM.
WITH AIR TRAFFIC AT A STAND
STILL, CIVILIANS AND FOREIGNERS
CONTINUE TO FLEE ON FOOT.
NEIGHBORING PAKISTAN SAID IT'S
ALREADY DEPORTED AROUND 50
FAMILIES WHO CROSSED INTO THE
COUNTRY WITHOUT PROPER
DOCUMENTATION.
>> PAKISTANI GOVERNMENT WILL
REMAIN THE SAME.
NO ILLEGAL MIGRANT WILL BE
ALLOWED INTO OUR COUNTRY.
THANK GOD THERE HASN'T BEEN U.S.
INFLUX OF REFUGEES SO FAR.
>> FOR THOSE AFGHANS LEFT
BEHIND, THEY FACE A TALIBAN THAT
IS CONSOLIDATING POWER WITH THE
NEW GOVERNMENT AND CRACKING DOWN
ON OPPOSITION.
PROTESTS ERUPTED AGAIN IN THE
AFGHAN CAPITAL OF KABUL AS
CIVILIANS DEMAND THEIR RIGHTS BE
RESPECTED AND THEIR COUNTRY
REMAIN SOVEREIGN.
TALIBAN FIGHTERS RESPONDED BY
FIRING THEIR WEAPONS IN THE AIR
TO DISPERSE THE CROWD.
>> THE ISLAMIC GOVERNMENT IS
SHOOTING AT OUR POOR PEOPLE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE VERY UNJUST AND
THEY ARE NOT HUMAN AT ALL.
THEY DO NOT GIVE US THE RIGHTS
TO DEMONSTRATE.
THEY ARE NOT MUSLIM BUT INFIDELS
AS YOU CAN SEE THE SITUATION WE
ARE IN.
[SCREAMS]
>> THERE ARE EFFORTS UNDERWAY
RIGHT NOW TO REOPEN KABUL'S
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT IF THOSE
TALKS WITH THE TALIBAN ARE
SUCCESSFUL.
IT COULD PROVIDE A WAY OUT FOR
SOME OF THOSE TRAPPED